I was born and I grew up in Ivory Coast,
and like so many other African kids,
I used to resent my Blackness,
including my hair.
I longed for straight hair
that could be easily managed and brushed.
After years of using hair relaxer,
I went back to natural hair at 16
after an incident with my hair
that forced me to shave and start over,
and it was a very hard new beginning.
But at 18,
while I was still in the process
of learning how to love my natural hair,
I came across a photo album
showing the hair of African women
in pre-colonial society,
and I was instantly inspired.
Seeing that photo album
was so powerful to me.
It made me see hair
completely differently.
Not just as a beauty tool,
but as a way to communicate
and to tell stories about who we are.
And immediately, I started
to experiment with my own hair.
I wanted to see what I was able to create.
And today I'm an artist
and hair sculpting is one of my media.
(Applause and cheers)
I use my hair to advocate
for what I believe in,
particularly for issues
that affect women and girls.
But it didn't start that way.
At the beginning, I was just
doing beautiful shapes
for the aesthetic aspects.
I started with doing simple
geometrical shapes
just for the beauty of it,
and when I was posting
those shapes online,
I was receiving so much love
that it encouraged me to push my limit
to create more complex sculpture.
From 2017 when I first started
until now, I’ve made
hundreds of sculptures.
Some can be playful,
others can be very serious.
So here are just a few examples
of what I can do with my hair.
Animals.
(Cheers and applause)
Random things, like an umbrella or car.
(Laughs)
(Applause)
Portraits.
Audience: Wow!
Text, like here where I write
“perfect” with my hair
because I do believe my hair is perfect.
(Laughs)
(Applause)
Cartoon.
(Laughter)
Sunflowers.
Fashion accessories.
Wings.
Even zodiac-inspired hairstyle
because my rising sign is Scorpio.
I'm another astrology freak.
(Laughter)
Medusa and even body parts.
(Applause)
Thanks.
The process to make the sculpture
is actually pretty simple.
The idea comes to my head,
I do a little sketch
and then I just sculpt,
using my natural hair,
some hair extension and wire.
I just wrap the braid around the wire,
and then it's very easy
for me to shape as I want.
And in general, you know,
to make the sculpture
being able to stand on top of my head,
the base needs to be extremely tight.
So if you're wondering,
is it hurtful? Yes.
(Laughter)
Yes it is.
But this is why, in general,
I quickly undo it after the photo shoot.
Most of the time I will take the picture
by myself, but when I need help,
my little sister, Florencia,
who is the most supportive
person on the planet,
will help me.
And depending on what I want to create,
a sculpture can take me from five minutes
to more than three, four or five hours.
When I started to create,
I was just doing, as I said before,
for the beauty of it, no meanings.
But it changed in 2018
when one of my photo series
went completely viral.
It was this one.
I shaped my hair
as a second pair of hands,
very playful, in various configurations,
and I started to receive a lot of messages
from Black women around the world
telling me that seeing my hair
helped them to feel better
about their hair, about their Blackness.
And I realized, OK, actually,
what I'm doing is pretty powerful.
So maybe it can just serve
a greater purpose
and I can use it to advocate for change.
So I decided to use my hair as a platform
to advocate for the equity of sexes.
Why this specific subject, you may ask?
Because I was born and I grew up
in an environment
that normalized the bad
treatment of women.
I have my experience,
many women have their experience,
so it touched me a lot.
And when it comes to equality of sexes,
I touch a lot of different subjects.
Unfortunately, I can't share
all of them with you.
I can just give you today a glimpse of it.
Bodily autonomy and self-love
is very important for me.
I went myself into a long process
towards self love.
Coming from a place where I used
to dislike everything about myself
to a place where I just love everything.
So I love to inspire myself --
(Applause)
So I love to inspire myself
from our female body
to create sculpture and shapes
that are associated with uplifting words
to empower those who need it.
And with this sculpture,
what I want to do is to encourage women
to have agency over their body,
but also to destigmatize all the classic
taboos around our bodies,
like, for example, periods.
(Laughter)
Aging, disabilities
and much more.
This sculpture, for example, was to --
(Laughter)
Was to address the big taboo
of body hair on women.
When I was 15, I posted a photograph
of me on social media
without realizing that my
armpit hair was visible
and immediately, the comments were wild.
"This is disgusting."
"Go shave."
"Ew, I can buy you a razor if you want."
I was traumatized,
so I deleted the picture
and after that I started
to shave way more regularly.
Even if, for me, it's a very
uncomfortable routine.
It took me years to be able
to love my body the way it is
and to embrace everything,
including my body hair.
Besides all the topics related to bodies,
I love to also address topics
related to our intellect as women,
because this world doesn't only encourage
women to dislike the body,
but also encourages women
to dislike what they have inside.
And I think just as we're supposed
to love our bodies,
we're supposed to also own our hopes,
dreams, our ideas or opinion
without shame.
And for that, I think --
(Applause)
And for that I think education
is extremely important.
This is why I did this sculpture.
(Laughter)
Unfortunately, in Ivory Coast,
many women still can't read.
When I was a child,
many women were working
at our home as nannies.
They weren't educated.
They would ask me to read
the text messages
because they couldn't.
In rural Ivory Coast,
many parents think that it's useless
to put a girl in school
because they are better at home
learning how to cook
or to take care of of the home
for their future husbands.
But when it comes to their son,
they are allowed to have an education.
So most of the time those women
will end up marrying older men,
and when those men abandon them,
they are left with nothing,
with very few career options,
because they are not educated.
And to me, this is revolting.
(Applause)
Growing up in an environment
where I wasn't always encouraged
to love who I was,
my journey has been about becoming
my own friend and advocate.
And when I embraced the capacity
I have to share my stories
and the ones of others,
I found the strength to advocate
for what I believe in
through my hair.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)